alors voyons faire [__] mais c'est
quoi ça
[Musique]
dernière fois elle n'est pas tranquille
aujourd'hui je me fais tatouer les
fesses voilà
je sais pas trop à quoi m'attendre en
termes de douleur par contre je sais à
quoi m'attendre en termes de réaction
parce que pas mal de gens ont déjà
essayé de m'en dissuader commencer par
ma copine et mes enfants qui m'ont
littéralement imploré de pas faire ça
mais alors ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
que si tout le monde m'a rappelé aurait
comme ça c'est parce que je vais me
faire tatouer cyril hanouna sur les
fesses pour le bien de la science à
l'ego bonne journée mais comment
j'allais son petit trajet en métro
[Musique]
la maison
alors avant d'aller sur théâtre ilcu
toujours se faire couper les cheveux
c'est en principe tu t'adresses à
d'urgents on dirait pierre cros c'était
mon nom j'ai mangé un morceau parce que
certains trucs eu l'estomac vide à mon
avis c'est pas une bonne idée pour des
partis pourtant avoir quelque chose à
nous on y est presque on approche fait
l'hyper froid je suis pas sûr que soit
le bon jour pour se mettre tout nu par
les imagine que le savant les chauffer
on va rentrer bientôt rendre à la mi
roman qui doit attendre d'être en retard
est plutôt en retard a pris alors
vraiment et pas juste en retard romain
était en retard il était en route et il
s'est rendu compte qu'il avait oublié du
matos lui donc il est retourné le
chercher chez lui donc il est en retard
tout en étant en retard en étant encore
plus en retard c'est même plus un talent
à ce niveau là c'est de l'art mais
comment elle est toujours aussi franche
me balade un peu dans le quartier en
attendant de pouvoir me faire tatouer le
cul ça fait monter un peu la pression
c'est cool merci romain larrieu
champions et de bonne humeur
[Musique]
les pinces à la basse a abondé toyer et
chaud
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
allez on est ce que là c'est trop tard
pour reculer
[Musique]
nous faisons allez on y va
julien c'est quand tu veux allez c'est
parti
en ce moment ça va ça pique un peu mais
ça va c'est pas encore pleurer démarre
aussi à défendre à caen petit à petit
j'ai là le muscle se contracte une seule
comme à l'aller sport-elec nouvelle plus
formaté de la chine théâtre tête et
manger un burger aux oignons
100 go prod numéro 2 ça le fait pas
sursauter
[Musique]
le plus déstabilisant c'est d'avoir une
personne que tu connais aussi peut aussi
proche de ton anus en fait
[Musique]
allez un bar garde magique changement
des équipes passage de relais sont
classés ama qui a pris le relais à
maquillage de particularités la première
c'est d'être à toulouse et la deuxième
c'est d'être le sosie de shy'm la
première fois que shy'm est aussi prêt
de défaite
vraiment c'était trop intrusif romain
général
voilà c'est fait
[Musique]
voilà le moment 9 septembre la découvrir
la bête un [__] de merde à la fois je
te trouve merveilleux et à la fois
j'étais des tests et tu me dégoûte un
peu
[Musique]